you date someone it didn't work out [ __ ]  happens life goes on  [Music]  [Music]  it's been forever what you've been up to  in Paris then I got engaged  amazing you come here often  my vineyard once before we saw it was a  bit before I dive Kosh died  I mean it's like what are we doing here  guess what I've just been doing you  should probably have the best sex I've  ever had you have like four minutes ago  all right we're not the absolute best  [Music]  what are you doing I'm just checking on  my boobs she is not fine how old do I  look  18 definitely are we drink white wine  spritzer I'll emanated that lady drunk  so her sister drinks oh she's trying  Oh marinara maybe it's not them they're  tiny and more like anything yeah  [Music]  like she told me about the time that you  drank too much at you though and  everyone Cody's [ __ ] shut myself soon so  woohoo - I do what we like